[Music]
lung cancer kills more people than any
other form of chima about nine out of
ten people die within five years of
being diagnosed with the disease if the
cancer is caught very early most
patients could be cured but doctors
struggled to diagnose early because
there are no symptoms until the cancer
is in its late stages and has spread to
other organs some experts think that
doctors should screen people at high
risk to find lung cancer before symptoms
appear
[Music]
the National lung screening trial in
America subjected 53,000 current and
former heavy smokers to either x-ray or
computed tomography scans every year for
three years its results reported in 2011
found that screening with CT scans did
save lives but there was a problem too
many of the lumps found during the
screening were not cancer this is known
as a false positive false positives can
harm patients who undergo dangerous
follow-up procedures such as biopsies
even if they do not have cancer it can
also affect their mental health and
false positives add to the cost of
health care according to new data from
the World Health Organization these
harms can be greatly reduced by
following a different protocol instead
of treating all lumps as a positive
result doctors are now advised to ignore
the smallest nodules and treat them as a
negative result this has half the rate
of false positives out of every 1000
people who were scanned 356 people
required follow-up testing under the old
protocol with the new protocol that has
fallen to one hundred and eighty
complications from follow-up testing
have also been reduced these results
show promise many countries are waiting
for the full reports of another trial
called Nelson before deciding whether to
set up fully fledged screening programs
preliminary data from the Nelson trial
suggests that screening reduces the
death rate from lung cancer among
high-risk men by 26% and 61% in women
if a balance between the cost and
benefits of screening can be found lung
cancer
need no longer be a death sentence
[Music]
coming up next what do we know about
Alzheimer's